I learned from my mistakes I can't come
to my clients and say I was a big
success and I'll be like me but I can
say I know what I did wrong and I can
help you avoid that so
um those are two things that are really
important in writing a good pen on
understanding the technology and
understanding the business and we try to
do both of those things welcome to 20
minute leaders just sit back relax and
learn from the leaders of today it's a
journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today we're talking about patent
creation invention protection of
innovation and we're talking with Daniel
kligler who's been doing this for quite
some time with a very interesting pivot
in his life
Daniel is the senior partner at kligler
and Associates patent attorneys he has a
doctorate in electrical engineering from
Stanford University and before becoming
a patent attorney he was a Founder
inventor and manager in two high-tech
startups he has a law degree and is
licensed as a patent attorney in both
Israel and the US and since the founding
of pliegler and Associates in 2008
clients of the firm have been acquired
for a cumulative total of more than 20
billion dollars The Firm specializes in
deep Tech computers Communications
Electronics Ai and high-end medical
devices with clients ranging from
startups through unicorn Ventures to
Fortune 500 companies foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
technology and patents and and and you
know Finding one's passion and finding
the right career path especially in
today's world where you know we have so
many different opportunities and so many
different things that uh that that this
new generation can do I'm you know it's
a really interesting question as to how
do we know what we want to do and and
how do we know when we've sort of found
something that will fulfill us so Daniel
tell me a little bit about yourself and
sort of your trajectory coming into the
patent world
okay well I started out as an electrical
engineer and an inventor
um I was in Academia for a while I was
involved in two startup companies
uh neither of which did very well which
is why I'm no longer in that world but
in the second company I was the VPR d
and I was responsible among other things
for our patent portfolio and we had
great patents
we were in digital video before the
field really developed and I thought
well we have great patents well we'll
for sure be successful
but we weren't because we didn't really
understand that patents aren't
everything that you need to fit in the
patents with your with your Market
depends need to serve your strategy that
was an important lesson and the other
important lesson for me was that
as the person responsible for the
patents I've got to know our patent
attorney very well
and when I left the company and I was
looking for what to do next
he invited me to come and train to be a
patent attorney in his firm
and at first it I thought about it for a
long time because my impression of
patents as an inventor was that they
were terrible boring hard to read I
couldn't imagine it would be interesting
but I said well you know what the hell I
need to do something new and so I went
and started training this patent
attorney and it took about two weeks to
realize that this is this was the job
that was made for me that I've been in
the on career and that what really
interested me was being a patent
attorney it's a great job because you
get exposed to all different sorts of
Technologies and for someone like me
who's a technology jock who just loves
the new technologies you get exposed to
the most advanced things from the from
the people who are leading in the fields
and so
it's endlessly interesting you know I
can see after 25 years in the job it's
still interesting
it's also a lot of writing and a lot of
work you know it's not for lazy people
but lazy's never been my problem
well so that's it yeah Daniel maybe you
can then give me a you know take me back
to sort of when you were
introduced to patents as sort of
something that you you may want to
pursue as a career right so you're
talking about this this change that
you've had in the mindset you've thought
about them in one way or now you're
thinking about them in a different way
I'm I'm guessing that most people around
the world are still in that older bucket
right of pre-transition share with me a
little bit about what what changed in
your perspective about about patents you
know why why are they something that
that you're so curious about and
interested in and something that's so
fulfilling for you
well let me start by saying
that the majority of patents are just
not good you know they're written by
people who don't really understand what
they're writing there's a joke about
pendants or he's a patent attorney or
someone who can write 40 pages about
something he doesn't understand at all
and so when technical people read them
they think well this is supposed to be
incomprehensible but that's not true a
good patent
is start off with good technical writing
it starts out with understanding the
technology because if you don't
understand the technology
then your patent isn't going to create
the kind of value that you wanted to
create
the point of a patent is to capture your
technology or strategic technology in a
way that you can monopolize and keep
your competitors from copying you
you know make them have to work around
you make them have to adopt inferior
Solutions so to do that you need to know
what you're writing you need to
understand how to write the pen then you
need to understand how how to explain it
to the examiner in the patent office
right
so
those are things
that
I think are are it's one of my
advantages in the job one of the
advantages of our firm is that I'm a
technology person and the other is that
I have business experience you know I I
learned from my mistakes I can't come to
my clients and say I was a big success
and I'll be like me but I can say I know
what I did wrong and I can help you
avoid that so
um those are two things that are really
important in writing a good pen on
understanding the technology and
understanding the business and we try to
do both of those things
so what what is what could be a a strong
impact of having a good pattern you
mentioned that most patents today are
bad but you know what what could be a
good result of having a good patent and
maybe if you can have some examples of
of ways in which you know good patents
were useful for an organization or an
individual that they'll be helpful
sure
um
I mean I think best if I just give some
examples from from my own experience
sure one of the clients
that I most enjoyed working with with
prime sense they developed the first
compact cheap consumer 3D camera if you
remember the Microsoft Connect
this was this game console with a with a
3D camera built into it so
um Microsoft
knew they had in their strategic plane
that they wanted to build this 3D camera
this 3D console
they acquired two companies with 3D
Technologies and tried to build this
camera themselves and they failed and
this group of young guys in Prime sense
had
figured out a new way to build a small
cheap and very reliable 3D camera and we
got great patents for them
patents that
pretty well closed off their particular
their particular approach now there are
other approaches right Microsoft tried
other approaches and filled but pront
has managed to protect their approach
very well when Microsoft went to build
the first generation connect they had to
buy their cameras from Prime sense
and then
um after that Microsoft
went off and did something else but then
Apple came along looking for 3D camera
Solutions and they eventually bought
Prime sense for I think it was 450
million dollars roughly
um a lot on the strength of their
patents which now below to Apple
and um
I can't really talk too much about it
but press Reports say that those patents
are still in use today so that's you
know that's a good example of how a
patent can protect a company basically
when you're a small company
if you're successful
the big players are just gonna see what
they can do to kick you out of the way
if you've got good patents it becomes
more expensive for them to try to work
around you than to buy you so they buy
you
um we've had some really big
Acquisitions in our
um in our in the history of our clients
so so that's one example
um another example is is melanox you
know whom I start I started working with
them shortly after they were founded
back this was more than 20 years ago
and they had this idea to make these
super fast
super fist communication adapters they
had the Insight that it that the date
would come when the limit on Computing
speed was not the computers themselves
but how fast you could get data in and
out and they were among the Pioneers in
that area they make the fastest
Community they still make the phases
communication adapters in the world now
it smelled like because there's not one
particular patent that distinguishes
them but they've over the years built up
a big and very strong pen portfolio very
dominant position in the industry which
I think was one of the reasons why
Nvidia bought them for as much money as
they did so those are a couple of
examples I I love it I want you to take
me into your own sort of your own
day-to-day in your own life and so you
you sort of mentioned before we started
the call that you know this was you know
you almost realize this is a calling for
you this is what you're you're intended
to do tell me a little bit about that
and why you know why this work speaks
directly to Daniel kligler why is this
your passion
well one reason that I already mentioned
was I think I mentioned was was that I'm
a technology jock you know I just love
learning about new technologies
and
you know as a patent attorney I get paid
to do that you know I get paid to talk
to the smartest people there are in
high-tech industry and to have them
teach me how their Technologies work so
that that's a great thing the other
thing that really speaks to me is the
entrepreneurial side
you know as someone who's been there and
understands what entrepreneurs are going
through that possibility to help these
people
along the road you know to to give them
a perspective that they don't have about
the intellectual property side of their
business and how it fits into their
business strategy that's very rewarding
for me uh these people you know almost
all of them these didn't by now are
younger than me and you know so it's
it's a very specific sort of I could
call let's call it mentoring that
um that I really enjoy and
seeing my client's success
is is just very royalty very it's
satisfying for me as though it were my
own success
although I'll say that you know we don't
take shares in any of our clients
there's some friends who do it's
something that we've consciously not
done
because I don't want anyone to come in
here and feel like he's a second class
client because I have shares in this
other client but not just pay me by the
hour so uh we want clients
we once one of my clients told me that
um even though he's a small company he
feels like sometimes like he's our only
client and that's how really I want the
clients to feel you know like they have
all our attention no one is more and the
big ones aren't more important just than
the little ones and and that's also a
great thing a great feeling of
satisfaction to help someone
Move Along his idea and see see his
business develop
phenomenal now if we're looking now at
companies and Founders Engineers
inventors what are what are some some of
the big things that we need to keep in
mind as we're you know creating these
inventions and how do we balance patent
creation into our daily life especially
is this something that like you're
mentioning a lot of people don't really
know how to do well so how do we
position ourselves to be successful with
protecting our inventions today in
today's world
yeah that's a very good and very
difficult question because uh
entrepreneurs
and also engineers in you know in going
concerns
are always overworked you know their
attention is torn in many different
directions and and an engineer will
naturally want to spend his time
developing the product and how you know
for him to have to spend time on the
patent application is a big distraction
he doesn't want to have to do that and
besides you know as I said before
patents are boring at least to the
engineers they are to the engineer
what's fun is inventing the patent is
already a distraction
um
so the entrepreneur entrepreneur needs
to consciously
set aside a certain fraction of his
attention
um investors will insist that he does
because investors know that patents
create long-lasting value pens will will
add to the company's valuation and
um
and so that's one source of that's one
place that patents get pushed up in
priority the other thing we try to do
is to reduce the load uninvent on
inventors uh that that's uh that's
difficult you know there there's also a
trade-off there we need to get inventors
to tell us as much information as they
can because more information makes it
better patent
uh but on the other hand we know
inventors are from are busy so we also
tried little clients prioritize we try
to
talk to them and understand together
with them which patents are important
which are going to give them a strategic
Advantage which are just nice to have
how many patents do you want to file
this year
um and then how do you choose the ones
that you're going to file so it's it's
an interactive process and we try to
get the information from our clients
help help clients understand without
taking too much of their time that's a
big challenge
fantastic no as we transition into a
feels like a new world where and let's
look at software for example as a
vertical and an artificial intelligence
and deep learning where we have a lot of
different researchers doing a lot of
different things in parallel we're
seeing for example natural language
processing we're seeing the fight for
you know the big the bigger models and
and different papers coming out you know
how do we even know what what is
defensible in a patented way and what is
not in today's world is is everything
defensible or are there different set
criteria that we can judge by
that's it that's actually an excellent
question and since you mentioned it
artificial intelligence it's one of the
really difficult areas to
to get patents
and to get patents that are worth
anything
a big problem in art is it there are two
issues with patents one is can you
convince the patent office to give you a
patent and if you've got a good patent
attorney usually you can the other is
will you actually be able to tell if
your competitors are copying or using
your patent and when it comes to AI
that's really hard because most of what
you know most of the secret sauce is
buried deep in the code
you know you don't know what's going on
in there you won't be able to tell if
you're if you're competitors are using
the algorithm that you invented and
patented and so it's very important in
those words
not only to find things that are
actually a technological and advance and
can be protected but also find things
that are detectable and so that's one of
the questions I always ask inventors how
are you going to be able to tell if your
competitor is doing this and often
there's a way
um
I've got a client's a company called
nanit they they make uh they make crib
cameras everybody who has babies these
days has a crib camera but what's smart
about net is that they use AI to analyze
the parents interaction with the baby in
the crib and give the parent tips uh so
we got them some good patents on that
because why is it a good pen well it
uses AI but it uses AI to capture it
also they analyze what the parent is
doing and so now
now there's something external something
that we can see that's outside the the
heart of the software that if a
competitor does it we have a pretty good
job of catching them uh that's one
example of a another example uh gong you
know makes these tremendously successful
systems for analyzing uh analyzing
um sales people in call centers they
they do they use NLP to
um track the
subjects in the conversations of the
salespeople and then they compare
the pet the conversation patterns of the
successful salespeople to the less
successful sales people and that way
they're able to extract tips to guide
the less successful salespeople so again
here's AI but it's AI that comes out
with something external detectable
um no I mean gun is a huge huge success
and it's mostly not because of their
patents but on the other the fact that
they have the patents gives them a leg
up you know and um
but they're a really big company already
but when the giant companies come along
so you know it's another reason why they
have to deal with scum
incredible Daniel I really appreciate
your time your energy are there this is
your your own net trajectory from
inventor to to doing this and continuing
to work with inventors and being so
curious about all the different things
you're doing and obviously so excited
about you know these inventions but the
way that you're then implementing them
into the real world through your own
personal
um personal stories from before and your
personal experiences so thank you very
very much for your time and for your
efforts and I look forward to continue
following your work and Diving deeper
into patents myself so thank you and
stay safe and stay healthy
my my pleasure thank you thank you
[Music]